the first royal tour to canada since the
start of the pandemic
[Music]
all the usual fanfare
and full of expectation a lot of people
complain that it costs the government a
lot of money but you know it's very nice
i think it's good to visit to the people
and listen them and to solve their
problems i think what's happened from
the caribbean tour is they quickly
adjusted and realized the old model of
royal tourists is not going to work in
in this century
prince charles and camilla are no doubt
aware of the criticism that other royals
have faced on recent tours to
commonwealth realms
indigenous groups and their concerns
prominent right from the start
[Music]
the stories are heartbreaking
the heart garden dedicated to the
thousands of indigenous children abused
and murdered in residential schools just
because of their heritage
some as recently as the 1970s
it is striking just how much they've
done to
pay their respects and show in front of
the cameras that they are here to listen
and to learn but acknowledgement is not
necessarily the apology that some people
still want to see
i did say
i hope we were too bad on you i didn't
get a chance to respond we moved on the
prince wally in this country uh you
should apologize to the aboriginal
people
for this trauma that we've gone to for
500 years
protesters had come out with other
grievances
but prince charles knows they have got
to hit the right tone with this
three-day tour celebrating the queen's
platinum jubilee is one thing making the
meaningful connections that people now
expect
is quite another
rhiannon mills sky news instant john's
in canada